all right Sicilian I'd have three do
this I would acquire a little bit more
information and again it rules out any
possibility for c4e for bind on the d5
square go with the bishop out
Queen d2 possibly that's a good
substitute possibly uh okay
cleanup queenside castle I'm gonna get
my F pawn rolling alright I'm gonna take
this guy this has happened I think on
stream before and I forget who I was
playing against my first thought is that
it was been Koji short okay it's a good
guess played a lot
I want my [ __ ] up here I think it was
my koji Bishop h5 that's where I want to
be I don't want to take this name so I'm
not going to because it repairs this
weak point d5 the b-pawn does well to
guard that so Bishop h5 is where I want
to be to pinpoint this guy I'd love to
get this night somehow right here takes
forever though the night trying to get
two squares diagonally from where he's
at takes forever I could get this in now
but to be honest I don't know how great
of a plan it would be everything is
pretty decent yeah I'm gonna round with
that yeah I'm gonna run with it I think
long term this could turn out to be a
ginormous pest actually you know what
here here it is it's I feel much more
confident now about making this move now
because I forgot about how valuable it
is for black to get their dark square
Bishop working namely age 5 and then
Bishop h6 with temple on the Queen so
it's annoying to this pawn long term as
well as the star square bishop
where do I want my where's my address
gonna be for my king I think I could
post up here right now and I think this
is gonna turn out to be a pretty big
problem there's I think many good
options right here queenside castle I'm
quite all right with the LightSquared
Bishop exchange mine they will love the
d5 square I may want to go there right
now
queenside castle King side castle there
is this half open G file
I like queenside castle I think
huh
I don't know there's no like some I'm
looking for reasons and I can't find
reasons to go with one move or the other
these candidate moves I have
and I don't I I can't associate a good
reason for doing this will opposed to
like kingside castle or 95 I don't know
let's say okay well now mmm this bishop
has kicked away from this square and I
think jumping into it right now is very
good
two deadly threats b6 f6 being more
deadly I think the queen is forced back
home and now rook e1 with f4 is
extremely difficult for black I would
not be surprised if there's just no good
solution now
all right
so now get this rook involved
hmm
all righty
f4 is very difficult I have all my
pieces working this night might want to
jump into one of these two squares at
some point
hmm
okay this is very difficult now however
is my opponent in a castle a king side
if King side castle comes into play
I think g4 and f5 is pretty good maybe
there was something better than f4 I
think the King is just gonna slip right
away and I have to be a bit careful here
these bishops are pointing right at my
king was that a misstep I'm gonna do
this first I want to keep this tension
because I might want to press forward
actually the more I look at it I think I
really would like to do that sort of
capturing or maybe it is best to capture
open the position I think opening the
position is just best then if if Bishop
e6 pawn push Bishop takes Queen takes
this point is defended and then I think
after Bishop f6 it's difficult to maybe
get at the King
so maybe just capture although then it
gives this knight a nice square hmm I'm
gonna do this I'm not gonna open up the
position I edit I don't want this night
or Bishop to be able to make use of this
e5 square so easily hmm so now Bishop
takes Queen takes is threatening mate on
f7 how to defend Queen to one of these
two and well this pawn is falling in an
endgame but maybe I want to keep the
Queen's on the board
I think getting off of this file is
important as otherwise my knight could
join the party by way of c5 of Queen d7
the knight can jump in I might want to
just do a pawn sack actually Queen here
maybe I'm gonna do this cuz now the F
file is gonna be opened up
and now this is really difficult to
defend very very difficult I do have to
be a little oh that check okay it's
still hit three times oh I guess there
is this pawn push now I was gonna say
have to be careful of a knight move here
I'd have to trade Queens now I can't be
played just yet rook takes or Queen
takes f6 is needed and I don't know I I
think this might be defendable here
there's no time for black but this is a
difficult structure to break down any
further f6 h 6 Wow
okay I can't this is not really
accomplishing much by playing here can I
chase the Queen away from defensive f7
not seeing it my bishop is kind of out
of play at this point I think I need to
reposition now it's at least watching
over c2 so if Knight here I could grab I
have this covered c2 and that was
interesting defense here by black I
don't think I have anything but now I do
I think King right here was good this
was a situation where the rook is
chasing my bishop away to square it
wanted to go to my rep doing something
and there's just no time now no time
alright good game BM 3 Fischer let's
let's go back what's the what's an
improvement
I don't think you should do that move
because of what I was able to do in
response I don't think this is a
favorable structure for black to have
sometimes let me I mean let me state it
like this sometimes white will
voluntarily take this night let's just
say let's say your queen plays to see
seven sometimes this bishop for night
exchange will occur automatically
unprovoked the bishop doesn't have to be
provoked with age six in order to take
the night sometimes it'll be done what
am I trying to say anyhow don't don't
don't play h6 here in short fumbling on
my words instead what could you do if
not h6 what else how about a 6 e six
Bishop e7 that's my suggestion
development yes you're in a temporary
pin but soon enough it'll be broken
Bishop e7 you're developed okay so this
is the structure we now have and well
this is extremely committal move e5 you
might want to consider at this point age
five then you can at least be assured a
pretty good diagonal for your bishop
and you'll certainly make me think twice
about castling queenside nasty skewers
if I'm playing f4 you could have maybe
e5 so anyhow consider h5 at this point
right here if you are gonna be faced
with this structure look to get in look
to activate your dark square Bishop this
is gonna be a difficult piece to get
working so maybe try and get it working
right away this is a very positional
move a quiet move but it has I think
very good long-term implications
so consider h5 right there instead of
the pawn
and maybe instead of that pond push just
go a single square keep just a small
group of pawns on this on your
sixth-ranked main reason that d5 square
I really want to have a pond I believe
around to watch over that now you need a
piece around to watch over that d5
square and I mean at the end of the day
you ended up defending but there's
there's no way that this position right
here can really be better for black and
a strong night here although maybe
castle there is a better defense this
definitely does look very strong to
looks right at there on the open files
stuff bound to happen very quickly but I
don't know if this was a mouse slip or
what I think it would have been when you
played King Daffy but anyhow at the end
of it all I think this is defendable I
told I missed the check I still think
it's maybe okay to have this but maybe
not you know I don't know how you how I
break this structure down any more
interesting game yeah all right good
game my pony is saying yes it was a
mouse slip okay there we go
confirmation so all right my opponent
did his best they could at that point
with their king on FA it didn't turn out
to be so bad